alexey navalny knows this drill well
he's been in the defendant's cage of a
russian courtroom so many times before
he knows judges almost never overturn a
conviction
he knows the chances of that are even
smaller for the kremlin's most
high-profile critic
so navalny listened to the expected
rejection of his appeal
and gave a customarily sarcastic reply
they've reduced my sentence by 1.5
months
great he said is the verdict clear asked
the judge
yes yes thank you answered navalny
taking off time already spent under
house arrest
navalny's sentence is now two years and
eight months
he gave a final statement captured only
on audio criticizing the authorities
they say what's this we can fiddle with
the justice system in any way we want
so how can you stand against us i'm not
the only one who sees it
but the ordinary people who watch this
can see it too they have bad feelings
about it
because they can imagine what happens if
they meet this justice system
outside his lawyer echoed navalny's
cynical view of the country's courts
today's verdict was expected for us we
consider it unlawful
nothing has changed all the arguments
were made in the court the first time
they got rejected then they got rejected
now
alexei navalny returned to russia last
month and was immediately detained
he'd been recovering in germany since
being poisoned on a trip to siberia last
august it was an attack which nearly
killed him
navalny says russia's fsb security
service was responsible
and the eu has sanctioned several
members of president putin's inner
circle
prosecutors say by being out of the
country so long
navalny violated the terms of an earlier
suspended sentence
after being released from the clinic on
september 23rd 2020
during two months till november 2020
alexey navalny has not notified the
probation department about his place of
stay
he has not turned up to the registration
either
but the courts were still not done with
navalny after his appeal rejection there
was another conviction
an eleven and a half thousand dollar
fine for supposedly defaming a world war
ii veteran
in one of navalny's online videos all
this legal attention
for a man the kremlin professes complete
disinterest in
a man whose political future they insist
is not their concern
rory challen's al jazeera